hi welcome to the video for those of you
that don't know me my name is Simon I'm
a PhD student at the University of
Exeter and in this video I'm gonna be
talking to you about books that I've
read recently whilst wearing a shirts
never seen an iron in its life
[Music]
in this video I'm gonna be talking about
infinitesimal Miami Alexander consider
fleebus by Iain M banks what if by
randall munroe and longitude by Dava
Sibel links to the Amazon pages for all
of these books are down there in the
description though where you can please
do try and buy books from your local
bookshop
because they're really worth supporting
I've also reviewed all the books I've
talked about in this video on Goodreads
I have a good reason which I'll again
link down there I don't understand
Goodreads particularly but if you'd like
to follow or friend me you can do those
things and I'll accept whatever so yeah
you can see what I'm reading and my
crude attempts at book reviews there
first up is imp intestinal this is a
book about well ostensibly it's a book
about a mathematical idea which is the
idea that you can take a curve any curve
and you can break it down into an
infinite number of infinitely small
straight lines this is an idea that's
actually been around since the Greeks
but it only really came to the fore of
mathematics in the 17th century and the
book says it's about that really I think
the book is about authoritarianism in
17th century it split into two the first
half of the book ish is set in Italy and
it looks at how the authorities in Italy
in particular Catholic Church responded
to this idea and the second half of the
book ish the first half is actually
quite a bit longer is set in England and
it's to do with how the state responded
the idea now while that seems like quite
a small remit for a book and maybe a
little bit boring this ties into an
awful lot of themes that go way way
further into the future the outcome of
well we know what the outcome was we
know that Italy after the 17th century
didn't produce any great mathematicians
sorry I realized that maybe a lot of you
don't know that while England then went
on to produce some of the greatest minds
in human history like Isaac Newton and
the book you know links really the
outcome of those two nations responding
to this idea in two different ways
depending on the degree of
authoritarianism in those countries to
the fact that Britain when isn't just a
revolution and then enjoyed an empire
whereas Italy didn't and like behind the
rest of northern Europe for quite some
time
like Western northwestern Europe really
and it touches on that it introduces
concepts of philosophy it talks about
Thomas Hobbes Leviathan because Hobbes
thought of himself as a mathematician
even though he went to his grave
convinced that he'd actually
accomplished what we've now proven to be
an impossible feat which is squaring the
circle and also the first part gives a
very interesting history of the Jesuit
Order which is a really basically a
militant part of the Catholic Church
about then it was founded as soldiers
for the Pope effectively and they went
on to become hugely influential in Italy
and they were one of the key people
groups of people that railed against
this idea of this mathematical idea now
if it sounds strange to you that the
state in England and the Catholic Church
in Italy should be concerned with an
idea like the bat that curves can be
broken down into straight lines read
this book because it it's not a part of
history I'd ever considered before
because it links maths you know very
very abstract concept to real-life
concerns and it maze makes links that
are perfectly logical and impacted Lee
research so I should point out there's a
huge number of references at the end of
this in many ways it's more of an
academic book than a popular fiction
book it's a little bit too dense for its
own good sometimes actually if I had a
criticism of it also the narrative in
the first part is a little bit like
pseudo chronologically goes
chronologically then goes back on itself
and back on itself which I found a
little bit annoying but it does it
argues its case very eloquently and very
satisfying me actually it runs a little
bit abruptly but if you're interested in
the history of maths and how Matt's has
influenced the world or even if you're
just interested in you in Europe in the
17th century I'd recommend this one
next up something completely different
Iain M banks is considered fleebus this
is the first book in the culture series
of novels by banks and it's the first
book of that series that I've read it's
actually the first book of this real
genre like hard sci-fi that I've read
and it took me a long time to get into
it I'll totally say that um similarly to
infinitesimal it can be quite dense in
fact somebody commented on the video
where I talked about this before about
the fact that they struggle to rename
banks because his imagination is so
vivid you have to sit and think for a
bit about what he's actually talking
about the idea is it is so out there
that you
kind of have to sit and think oh goes
around the world but as well building
goes I mean I'm a big big fan of the
100,000 universe and the books that are
associated with that and that is a very
dense deep deep world that's been built
by by well dozens hundreds even if
people this is one guy and the depth is
crafted is just astonishing
it's like Philip Pullman assistant
materials in the depth of the world
that's been created and it's it's very
satisfying well building level the pot
is also different to what you'd expect
from sci-fi in a lot of sci-fi Doctor
Who is great example you will find a
protagonist that changes the overarching
situation of the story is set in and in
this book it's the exact exact opposite
the protagonist and the events of the
book have next to no impasse in fact
they basically have no impact on the
setting on the great war that's going on
in the background the small events of
this book are quite small don't have any
impact and I quite I found that quite
refreshing mostly this is about personal
interactions and introducing this
amazing world of the the culture which
is like a communist utopia in the far
future where machines are far far more
intelligent than people will handle you
have rights associated with them and
contrasting that with a very warlike
theocracy of an alien race and the
characters viewpoints or well the main
character at least viewpoint changing on
the two sides as the book goes on the
prose instantly is really quite lovely
it's not beautiful in a lyrical sense
but every now and again a sentence just
catches you and I really love that I'm
not quite sure how to recommend it too
if you're into psiphon you haven't read
it
definitely definitely read it if like me
you find ideas of machine consciousness
interesting I can also recommend this
also if you like quite pulpy sci-fi dip
your toe in this and see what you make
of it because I based on this I'm going
to give some of the other books ago I
think maybe not quite yet because I've
got a lot of like it's as it is but um I
enjoyed it they were warned that it is
yeah quite dense
next up something completely different
again what if I ran the Munroe I'm not
gonna spend too long talking about this
this is a collection of Randall Monroe's
responses to his fantastic blog what
which it's online you could read it free
this is just a collection and I think a
few extra ones as well in print form if
you if you like problem solving
basically if you're thinking of going to
you need to do a science subject or if
you're at uni doing a science subject
goodness sake read this book and in
particular if you're pairing from Oxford
physics interviews or Cambridge Natural
Sciences in fact generally Oxford
science interviews read this because the
questions on the important thing how he
tackles the questions that the process
by which he attacks a problem is exactly
what they're looking for in interviews
and it's also an awful lot of fun like
an example question from what height
would you need to drop a steak for it to
be cooked when it hit the ground now
that's a question I have no practical
impact on your life whatsoever but the
process by which you answers it is
fantastic so yeah if you're a scientist
or if you if you geeky in like plodding
problems give this one read next and
last for this video long achieved by
Dava Sibel this is a really we little
bit look like 170 pages long and it is
about the creation I've still got a
bookmark in there that's train ticket it
is about the creation and invention of
first maritime clocks so basically
determining latitude so the distance
from the north you are from the North
Pole downwards if you like is easy you
can do that by looking at stars anybody
who was at sea could could do that very
easily but longitude is more difficult
there was no easy way to determine down
longitude up until events this book
which takes place in the 18th century
and that was a big problem people would
crash and die all the time and there
were two techniques which people came up
with to determine longitude one was to
set the clock to London time and then to
observe where you were what the noon was
and then the difference in time between
your clock and your observation gave you
how far east or west you were and the
second technique was to use an
astronomical method which had its flaws
in fact they both had their flaws
because clocks up until the events of
this book at least would just not
accurate on ships and that was the case
until this man sorry I missed him there
is this man John Harrison came around
and the story of under him inventing
these clocks is it's very interesting
and happy he had personal competition
with the astronomical method by the
astronomer royal
who I think is villainized a bit
unfairly in this book but it makes for
interesting narrative basically this is
yeah it's very light it's frothy it is
not an academic text it is very easy to
read very short chapters only about 10
pages so it's ideal to read before bed
which is what I read a lot of it in fact
I read about half of it fully on the way
to go and see the clocks the Harrison
made which are at the wall Observatory
in Greenwich which is a lovely place and
and you can you can see if you live in
London the the clocks that are there
which are beautiful I've got to say it's
a little inconsequential it doesn't
really stick with you that much after
you don't get the impression of reading
anything particularly profound but it's
enjoyable if you're if you're after just
something kind of light to eat in bed
then give this one a go and that's all I
have for you in this video the schedule
for this video series is basically gonna
be determined by how fast I read stuff I
I this represents about five weeks of
reading I think I've been reading quite
a lot recently and it depends on how
much time I have from my PhD and if I
have good stuff to read and I feel
inclined to read it in the next video
I'm currently finishing off Game of
Thrones and one book six and I've got
seven just by my bedside table so
hopefully the next video I will have
learned through the next Oh God about a
thousand pages and I'll do a sort of
series review of the whole thing if you
maybe if you've seen that that's shown
yeah the books and you want someone to
give you a skinny of what I like then
that will be videos like and then I've
also got coming up Galileo's daughter
I've got the job Dora look I've got a
movie review book that I've got two
movie books I've got a genie Gene Kranz
is portable cofee book on quantum
mechanics there's I could I could do
this house for quite a while I think
what I'd like to do in this series
however is if you are in the middle of
reading Game of Thrones maybe or if
you're just if you ain't thinking about
it maybe like to start leaving them next
video let's have a discussion in the
comments thread about Game of Thrones
and what we think of the books and me
the comparisons to them and I hopes for
the next one maybe the fact that it will
ever come out but and in this video I'd
like you if you've read these books
below to comment maybe
you get them a quick review of your own
and if you based on this video go and
read them come back leave a review and
I'd really really like to get some kind
of interaction with you because I know
the people that watch this channel are
big into books like me because you and I
love talking to fellow geeks so that
into that conversation is something I'm
really really looking forward to having
if you have recommendations for stuff
that I should read and I already have
about a million based on my favorite
books video which instantly if you
didn't know is a thing I'll put that up
there if you have recommendations
perhaps based on the fact of what I
liked and dislikes about these books put
them down below I'm keen to see what you
guys suggest and yeah ok from there it's
quite exciting starting new series if
you like this video do give it a like
and share it with your your book coffee
friends and hopefully I'll be seeing you
in a couple of weeks time thank you very
much for watching the bait I described
with my friends is like literary dark
chocolate and don't much you want a
little bit of the time and when you do
have a little bit of time yes not one
for everyone if you feel if you feel
like ambitious then
but it does raise the question of me
which I I personally think that I have
and we mean with a performant display
you like it's like an online persona